Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier.
And welcome back to Inside!
Now, we're gonna find out where these guys are
going.
I'm not 100% sure I want to know.
Oooh.
[grunting]
There we go.
Okay. A bird flew by just as I
did that.
So, is that-
[grunting loudly] khpoooh!!
Awe man, why can't I boosh away!?
I'm not good at "The Pull".
Oh. Well I guess that's all right then.
Can I go down now?
Thank you.
Alright, so where am I going and why was I hearing a heartbeat out there,
but it's kind of muffled in here?
Ugh, this seems bad.
[sounds of struggling]
Okay, ow.
So where am I now?
And why am I descending into the sewers?
It seems like a bad thing,
but then again, I don't really know what's good
for me.
So, I'm going to keep going forward.
Habugh!
Nope that didn't work.
Maybe I gotta push it from the other side.
Yeah!
Heh heh heh heh heh heheheh!
I'm too smart for you! (x2)
Me am big brain have and do smart good!
Okay
Whoa, what is that?
What is tha-
ohhh noohohoho!
Oh man! That startled that guy on the
ground, apparently.
Oh, God
But wait, he's got a wire on him.
Why did I turn that on?
That seems like it was a bad move.
Euuugh!
EUUUUAgh!
Why did I do that?
Euaaaaagh!
EuaaAhAhgh!
Is anybody ever seen that Rock video?
I-I just did a video with The Rock
Um..
You can see it,  I'll put a link in the
description, but it's over on his channel
that he just started because he wanted
to start a YouTube channel, which is
really admirable like, I'm actually
impressed that he would be interested in --
Oh! I've made a horrible error!
Ahh! My neck! My back! I'm not going to say
anything else because I don't need to!
Anyway, but yeah, so have any of you
ever seen the video of that-
What happens if I just don't turn them
on? Oh, yeah! Th-this is much better.
Oh, this is much better. Oh okay, so I had just goofed!
I just goofed real hard. Ehboi. So I gotta
open this, and then turn on, and THEN go
through it all.
But there's a video of The Rock, uhm, from his
wrestling days
*laugh* and it's just a remix of 'eheaugh.... eheaaaaugh...
eheaahUAhAUH! EheauaaUAHUagH!
Can you smell-l-l-l-l-l-'  and just that over and over again! It's not funny when I do it,
but trust me, it's funny when he does it! *laugh*
I swear, it's not funny when I do
it but I, I SWEAR it's really funny!
It's like, guaranteed to cheer you up
on the darkest of days.
HA! You can't get me you light 'flinking' bastard!
I don't know who made you, but you are
god damn bizarre.
Anyway so go look that up, it's really
funny. It's just- I believe the video
title's just called 'Can You Smell What
The Rock is Cooking?' but i'm not 100%
sure, *long inhale* and I think the actual quote is 'If
you smell what The Rock is cooking'.
What you got over there little birdie bird? Mmmmm,
I'm gonna take it from ya! Uh oh, that don't
seem good. Euuugh!
Something seems bad! It's getting pretty
stressful in here... what happens if I-ahh shit!
Nggah! Ahhh! Uh oh! Sorry!
What did I do? Oh, God. Well, that's not
good. Don't mind me!
I'm fine! Uh, I am d-door *laugh* Smart. Smart kid.
Smart, smart, smart, smart, smart kid.
This kid's sooooo smart! Op! Eh de doo doo.
Edgee. Twitch! Can I twitch? Ahh! God damn it! It was tryin' to twitch!
Now I'm twitching too much! Ohhh, I see, okay. *sniff*
Well, I mean, I already saw it. I'm just
gonna do it less stupidly this time.
Blut bloot- Keep your head down son! What
are you doing? And stop.
Yeah. You ain't seen nothin' with me! I am
normal!
I'm normal human! Normal everydays, lik
will stolen human.
Normal everyday puppet in a gosh-darn
human skin bag everyday human.
Ugh, why are we stopping? Why are you still
looking at me? I'm not suspicious.
Stop staring you creep.
oh boy
Okay, see? Good. See, I'm good!
Ohh! I gotta ju- I gotta jump! Oh, okay! Oh, this is gonna go well!
Oh, this is gonna go really well. Ehhbudeh! Oh boy, oh boy....oh boy... Oh, okay,
we got it. Ehhh-heheheHEHE!
I know what I'm doing! I know what I'm
doing even though I'm a different color.
Op. EhhdaAHH! Fuck! God damn it! I didn't mean to do that!
No one seems to be perturbed! I didn't
mean, God damn and I-
that wasn't my fault that's not- *angrily* it's
not my fault!
No-no one pay any attention to me.
I'm terrible, I know... I know I'm
terrible. I'm aware... Yerp.
Flip badoo! Okie dokie then! Ship-a-dip!
Shop patoop pata!! Everyone is
so impressed...
Schoimp! Okay. Ship-a-dip shop shoop bap, boobadoo,
bip badoop badup bap!
Shump! Okay! Aannd I'm out of that! Shep ba bo doo ba doo! What I gotta do to
impress you?
Herbp! Ohh, okay. All right I can do that!  I can
do that! I'm already been i'm good at all
these things, I just didn't do it at the
right time.
Shöp, ship... Okay. Heh heh. *maniacal laughter*
heheheh!  I'm the master of this....
*more maniacal laughter* I think I can get out of here. I don't
need to be in the next batch. Hep! Heh ew!
Yeah, I don't look at the camera kid. It's
not gonna help you at all.
Alright. Oop! Uh oh.  Are we good? Are we good?
Okay, I think we're good. Oooh! that was a
creepy part.
*inhale and faint, increasingly louder heartbeat and zombies in background...*
Well that sounds bad!
Is that our inevitable fate that we're *crunch*
marching towards?... Oh no.
Oh.
Uh oh.
*evil dog sounds* Ahhh! Oh God!
Okay, well that was bad!
ohhhh! I don't know what I diiiiid wrooong! Probably
because I just wasn't supposed to be
over there. Oh, the camera's still looking
at me.
Maybe I got to make a break for it.
I probably gotta make a break for it... oh boy.
Okay! Ahh dada lat da loot doo doo ba doop! Ba doop, ba doop!
I'm fucking out of here! Ahh! Oh, gosh you
came too close!
Hi! How's it going friends? How you doing
you faceless bastards?
Oh, you're beautiful faceless bast- *scared noises*
Oh, god damn it! I did a-
I stopped. I was not aware that I needed
to... *inhale*
That's a lot of death happening. That's a
lot of death. Oh, he so proud of what
he's done.
I'm not though. Okay, so there's got to be
like, I obviously can't beat him there,
so there's something else to be done. Where ya goin'?
Oh! Oh, oh! Faked you out! Ho hoo! *uneasy sounds*
*screaming* Oh, God damn it!  I almost faked you out.
I almost... Ohhohoho, it's so sad!
Okay! Third time's the charm! A lot of
death happening but you don't need to
worry about it it's fine! Totally fine.
Get ready. Alright. Get ready for the
most epic fake out of predeterminedology
of the world! Oh!  How the fuckin'
god damn that's not...
That wasn't supposed to happen... that uh,  that
wasn't supposed to happen.
That was the opposite of what was supposed
to happen. I don't know why that
happened THAT time and not the other time but
maybe...
Okay, hang on... hope
hoop hoooo. Okay. NOW we can make it!  ha Ha ha! ha HA ha!
You so stoopid! Okay,  push me! Boosh me!
Whoop, hey come back here! Hey, come back here. Boosh me! Okay, bye! Bye you weird dog.
I hope you get infected with wormz-uh! Okay. Boy,  that's gotta put a lot of
strain on this kids neck to be attached
to this so proclariously.
You heard me, proclariously! Heh, bleh. Okay.
Bye, buddy. You've had good time. You be
good ehhhhhhhhh
Ah! Why I'm not booshin' this? Ha-boosh!
Aahh. Oh, wait but it's a caaaatch.
Okay, so I gotta be back over there. Dang it! I didn't know! How was I supposed to
know!? That's what I get for trying to
boosh too early. Man, I was just so ready
to boosh. I finally got an opportunity,
I just had no idea what I need to do.
Haboo-boob! Grab and pull! *sounds of struggling*
Okay, let go.
I'll be back you have fun! Take care! I
still hear that stupid dog in the
distance but I don't need to worry about
him I just need to worry about what I'm
doing over here. Okay, got it! I'm on my way. Hope you
didn't go anywhere good buddy.
Mmm. Okay. It's starting to look a little better
but I'm imagining this whole city has been
taken over by some sort of, what I can
only assume as, alien menace.
And I'm not sure about that, but I can only
assume because I'm stupid and by
assuming things I make it unobvious
that I'm unintelligent.
If those goddamn words made any
bit of sense. I don't need to be this far
Ahh! This was a horrible error. Why do I
need to be over there? There's something
above that
so there's something up there, but how
can I get up there is the question.
No, there's something definitely up there
and down would only be death, so...
Oh! Of course! I'm actually controlling
the guy! I forgot that I was actually
controlling him which means that there
is-
Whoa... There's like, a second helmet
What happens if I- what happens if
there's two guys in a helmet? Whoa, oh!
Heh hey hey!
Hahaha! Oh! Double puppet activities going
on here!
heheHEhehehey! That is frankly, pretty dang weird. Ahhh.
Okay.
That is bizarre. The music even got a
little more interesting about it but,
what can I do about this?
So. If I now drop out of, I'm, oh! I know
what I need to do! I need to have this
over here so, whoops!
Don't be dead, please! So I can, I can drop
myself over here. He can still climb up
here drop out of there,
I can get this back,
he can come back and we can keep going!
Thank you buddy! You to take me up there!
You're doing a wonderful job and I
really appreciate everything that you've
done to help me thus far!
You're an amazing person! Although, i
don't know what benefit this technology
does when you have to do the exact
movements that the others doing.
It's not exactly anything besides I
guess a force multiplier but, only if
you're doing the exact same thing many
times across.
Woah. That's probably surprising to them. Ooooh! It's a spooky gate!
OooooOoooh nooOooO!
Okay do I drop down there? I think I
drop down there. Hang on, I got.... a I got that
They're very worried about this. They'll
be extremely worried in just a hot second
when I'm actually able to do a son of a
bitch about this stupid thing.
Not ththe the stupid! I'm just
saying I'm stupid for not being smart
about it which is all the everyday of my
life.
goodbye! goodbye goodbye goodbye. AAAAAAH A bloosh!
oh I bet this water is fun and
definitely hygienic it need air. I almost
choked on my own spit
sorry *HUEGHPLUH*  Ok so what is this?... Do I need
to do- I saw this in the corner and a
*ah bluski*
good thing it was colored because
otherwise I wouldn't have known about it
oh that's awesome
but what does that mean do i need to
boosh this over here - Do I finally need to
boosh something okay
that's exactly god damn it stop being
stupid stop being a silly Billy for once
in your life and boosh the damn thing
reminds me when I was playing last of us
and Ellie needed to get in the goddamn
palette, "ELLIE!"
*coughing* Ellie come over here i'm dying
*more coughing*  Ellie this is my last dying wish
just be a goddamn friend all right here
we go
got it I figured out the puzzle because
I'm smart and I have brain big who else
is here
who else is going try murder me
besides everyone which is the main problem
OH BUTTON I press it right away! HA BOINK. Oh. Is that a good thing?
Oh good! This seems excellent
OooOh but-ton! I'll push that HA BOINK
Mmm very good. So that was nice.
Uh oh. Too high! Too high!
Oh, just high enough. Can I leap out of the water like a fish? *sure, go ahead*
ok so there's gotta be something that I
can push onto the water that's gonna
help me reach that chain
so there's gotta be something around
here somewhere
*struggling* oh I'm so strong *noise continues*
Okay, got it yup no just kidding, faked you out.
right so that gets me back in here... oh
got tired so all this would do is this
would reset the water level which is
exactly what I just did
soooo it would only lower the water level
which I don't think actually helps me
because all i did was just get back in
this area
huh
soooo that door is open now
ooooh wait a minute
if there's a way to flood this area if I
can somehow break the system I can keep
the doors open and flood them but I
don't know if that's proper way of going about it
So there is a way- huh, okay
yeah because these doors they close
automatically when the water level rises
so there must be some way
OH I know I I gotta go get um I gotta go
get something from the other room
because it's got to be because when this
is here that means the other door opens
right?
no? Goddamnit okay I'm officially stuck
for the first time in this game I'm
stuck so there's gotta be something
obvious that I'm missing
what if I what if I hit the button from
here
I just swim down to hit the button and
try to get to the upper ledge before
that happens
heh heh heh heh heh heh
yeah he- There we go! Okay that did it! Well
that was good enough but what did I- Oooh.
it's dark in here yeah
Ah that is- that is ominous
that is what one would call ominous. OH!
but I got this I don't know how I got it
but I got it okay so i got this and if I
pull this out there- oh I need to BOOSH IT!
I finally need to boosh something for once in my goddamned life. BOOSH HE HOYO AYE
okay we got this- nope drop down. *singsong* booshie
Boosh Boosh Boosh! I'mma boosh ya Ah boosh you all
the way outside and then when you're
outside you'll actually be floating and
you'll be able to get me where I need to
go but the thing is i need- no you're fine
there
so why would I ever need to go back into
the place?
there must be something for the future
like I I just don't understand it right
now
heyeah it would have been terrible if this thing didn't actually float
heh, he- Okay, there we go. And then up and
then where does this go
HI! Don't mind me once again. Wow that
seems like normal society why is
everyone a zooOombie?
maybe that's just the lower labor force.
Man isn't this kid getting-  Oh my GOD!
oh mY GOD, that's a lot of people
that's a lot of people. *Markiplier jumping noises* that's
lovely the way that the shadow moves
Can I-
*Markiplier imitates didjeridu* OH GOD. OH GOD.
IT FINE. I didn't know exactly what i
needed to do before i started doing it
so I mean- that is a huge line of people
Oh man that's too many people. Reminds me
of Half-Life, City 17 the lovely world that that-
bri- AAAAAH BLEH. shit. fuck. ass.  ow, my spiiine
well every part of me broke but that's
fine because I'll be getting getting
along- Wow, I messed up my hair royaly
but no one pay attention to that
everyone pay attention to the amazing
skill that's about to be seen in front
of you today-  EHEHEHEHEH OHOHOHOHOHO that's
what I call skill, baby!
That's what I call skill! Ah, I'm hooked on skill... heh, eh
it's kill la sKILL here *hehe*
It's Skill-inator 2: Skill-ment Day
It's Skill-hog Day.
Nah, "Ground-Skill Day"? I don't know. I-I- I can't think of clever things when I'm
on the fly
Okay *imitades running noises* Okay
I made it! What good does this do me- oh,
that! Uh, that's not good
AAAH! I'M GONNA DIE!! OH GOD! *Mark laughs* Oh jeez, good thing I dropped all the way to the booOOoox. The box is my
safety net
I love the box! The box of the beEest
Okay. Come on back here, whatever the hell you are. You're obviously not a
helicopter so you're just a monitoring
station on the roofs for sooOome reason
like, why would they need to have a great
big searchlight here on the roof?
Just seems counterintuitive-
counterinTUITIVE COUNTERINTUITIVE  WOOOOH! We made it
maybe it was a secret over there on the
right but I doubt I could have gone all
the way over there
So, for now, I'm gonna count my blessings and just stay over here
I'm gonna make it!
I'm gonna make it!!
WHOOAAOO!!!
i made it
I'm gonna make it!
I'm gonna make it!!
wheehhh
i made it
im gonna make it
What the hell's going on over here?
oh, nothing
I'm gonna make it!
I'm gonna make it!!
HOOO
ok
Down we go.
OOoOOooO
This looks baaad
oOoOOHH
aAaAAH
That's where that train went!
okay.
*Strange Noise*
What is that noise?
There's NOISES here o.0
I don't like NOISES!
Noises is badses..
Euh, that's bad
euh, man.
I mean, so far, there's nothing supernatural going on in here, but it's-
Der's Doggos
OOHHH
I see some Doggos over der!
There's some Doggos
How you doin', Buddies?
You doin' good?
It's good to know there's still rampant electricity running through all these old, decrepid, Tuuube Trians
and that there's Doggos chewing on something that must be some sort of a fresh kill.
All bad.
Every every of this is bad.
Don't spot me!
What ever you do,
if you spot me, I swear, I'm gonna smack you upside your head
okay
*Distant Growling*
Aw man, these doggo  EUGH
*Distant Barking*
ok BYE!
He's onto something!
Not Me,
but he's onto somethin'
ok
weeee-
-eeee
Nothing down here?
Doesn't look like nothing down here.
ok
*drowning impression*
So that doggo ran over here.
I have a funny feellin'
*The Echos of Distant Barking*
*Muffled Barking*
AH- OH GOD
OH GOD OOHHH
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT WAS POSSIBLE!
I HAD NO IDEA!
Maybe if I dive REAL deep.
Eh Eh Eh ... Eh
*Muffled Barking*
*barking continues*
You can't get me, I'm too deep.
I'm too deep.
uh-oh
oh I should've gone far- oh I should've gone farther in
I should've gone farther in
OOHH I SHOULD'VE GONE MORE
EUGH SHE'S BETTER AT GETTING OUT OF THE POOL THAN CHICA WAS
AAAHHH
OKAY, EVERYTHING'S FINE (no it aint)
Ohh... this seems bad.
AHHH! It is bad!
It was exactly as I predicted!
AHHH! Pull it off! Pull it off! UGHHAHH!
Oh God no! Oh God no!!
AHHH! I should've just crawled under!
That would've been smarter.
I should've just danced with them back and forth
and pulled off one board... Ohh, that's bad.
Oh, that looks bad...
One board at a time!
See? What did I tell you at the beginning of this?
I would've found all the ways to die.
Okay, so I just gotta get one board.
*heblu...buu*
Okay. Go! Go! Go! Go!
Go, Buddy! Go!
Heh. Heh Heh. Heh!!
Stupid dogs!
You're so stupid!
Look how stupid you are!
What a bunch of "stups"!
eh eh eh... egh egh egh ha HO!
*Laughs* What a bunch of stupid idiots!
*Laughing* So dumb!
Uh oh... uhh... so dumb... So dumb...
So Dumb So Dumb So Dumb!!!
Ahh! So dumb! Wooo!!
Okay...
Hello! Come get me, pups... come get me!!
Ho ho ho! Fresh meat for the eating!
Rwoah... Bite my butt you silly bitch!
Okay, we're good so far.
Ehhh... this should be enough to get through!
Okay... Through! Through! Through!
[Burps] Okay, we're good.
That was a victory burp right there.
Woo! Nelly...
Whooo Nelly, Okay
So that is probably all the time that I got for this episode
thank you everybody so much for watching
that was a bit of a crisis to get through
there but I got it through EXPERTLY because of
just how brave I am so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
buh-bye!
*top video* OH YEAH! OH HI! OH MY GO- OKAY, FUCK OFF
*bottom video* CKING Hell, good God! Oh you sack
of shit! *bye guys!*